we don’t call Olga Klinka, I’m Poltavchenko, I took part in the Maidan and the very first rally, which seems to be all 24 leaf fall 2013, rock naked Kyiv and all Ukrainians leaned out their visible shen before the European integration of Ukraine, we went out so that the water about the association was signed, I demanded it was and honestly didn’t ask screws even on the Maidan to the protsu you the view of the indoor university Maidan both actors and people’s deputies performed there and at 4 and there were oregano whom I’m all the devas thousand and the shots to the Maidan from the side you can up to 1000 mm and gum like mica and brush hil nebula to extremism both to such a solution to problems that we wanted, but for three months the Maidan stood in the minds of a full and, after all, you didn’t solicit the bark 100 watts, which still brought down the ill health of poverty, cola, you oden oden the system and supposedly a mouth and you would you maesh bureau thousand a